welcome to today's episode of the
waterlab podcast i'm james marshall
and i've got a real good guest for you
today but firstly a quick mention
of our sponsors who have helped bring
this podcast to you firstly straight
face raisers
have a deal for what led listeners which
is 50
off your first order which you will get
four sharp five blade heads
and a razor delivered to your door to
get your hands on one of these bad boys
head to the waterlab.com
and click the straight face logo it's
definitely worth a try see for yourself
how good this product is
also todd's racing they're training
winners for absolute fun
so go give them a follow on facebook and
twitter
or if you're looking for a trainer look
no further than the lad regan
todd what a legend what a lad also
woodland coffee wood's finally starting
to spread how good this brew is
if you have coffee at your home go order
some water lead coffee next time you've
run out you will definitely not regret
it anyway let's roll the intro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right oh well it's not often you have
someone post on social media that hits
home
with so many people and today's guest he
shared what he'd been going through
and why he hasn't been playing and man
so many people could relate to this post
not just in rugby but in life he's also
a new zealand rugby star having played
for northland tasman waikato
as well as the chiefs and is currently
with the highlanders in southland
but above all he is an absolute lad
who's happy to help others by sharing
his experience
it is the great solomon alamello welcome
brother
cheers hey now honestly thanks so much
for coming on um
that post you put up the other day like
i said it was has affected so many
people so many people have
been moved by that so how's it been for
you um
oh good man like um i was probably
yeah i was real nervous about posting
and stuff but um
yeah just real surprised that just the
overwhelming support and
you know just how many people are in
that sort of similar position
that have reached out so real i'm
overwhelmed by the support
yeah mate you got like 500 comments and
stuff everyone's sending their love your
inbox must have blown up as well what
what people sort of messaging yet um
i think yeah for me but i was like all
the people i didn't know a like um and
just like uh the younger footy players
too
just reaching out are just stuff around
uh
they really appreciated the
vulnerability and the
openness of the post and um just their
own they felt like they're in a
similar situation and um it just really
meant a lot to them that they weren't
alone sort of thing so uh
they really had home for me bro and um i
really appreciated that they were
vulnerable enough to sort of reach out
as well and be open to me so
that was cool it was kawaii and there's
vulnerability sort of
is contagious say like once one person
becomes vulnerable and opens themselves
up then
everyone feels like they are now more
comfortable to be vulnerable as well so
what you're doing has been
massive and obviously the effect that
you've seen already
um must be pretty it must be pretty cool
appreciate it appreciate it
so what made you sort of do the post
when did you sort of get to the point
that
may i i need to share this journey so i
i always sort of felt that um
i wanted to to like open up as i was
sort of going through the process
of it as i was going through like my
return to train and stuff but
it was just sort of finding the right
time because as well as our boys like
sort of gone to the final two and i
didn't want to take away from that
and yeah it was just more about the
timing so uh just when i sort of felt on
a rise and
um in terms of just how i was feeling
and stuff um
yeah i just sort of felt probably the
right time then but
yeah it was actually one of my boys that
uh posted in our group chat man
johnny who us check posted like a weird
video like a chicken on on your mates
and
just numbers around business personal
and uh or mind health um
and just sort of posted it but he's
never been one to sort of open up like
that and um
get there so um that was at like 12 in
the morning man so
and i woke up like five and i was just
like sort of
um just reflecting on my own journey and
my notes and then um
yeah like two hours later just finally
found the courage to
to post it and um and yeah it was like
seven in the morning
but yeah i was just you know real
grateful that i'm just overwhelmed that
everyone's sort of in support of it so
now it's cool
and and how are you feeling now you're
feeling good within yourself
yeah man yeah i think it's just um yeah
like yeah it's not always going to be
perfect day like in um
there will be those days but i've got
like uh like more tools than i did
um at the start of it to sort of uh
handle that
i've got a lot awesome support system as
well
my fiance and um her family and my
family too and
all my bro and stuff and yeah so i've
got the tools there it's just um you're
just recognizing
like when i am starting to get in that
slumper well right now man i'm just in a
real good head space and looking forward
to
mitres in there too so you're going to
be hissing for southam this year
when you say tools what sort of tools
have you got and what sort of lessons
have you learned from it
um just acknowledging that that i am
in that spot you know like um you know i
am feeling that way for
for a particular reason or for a certain
reasoning just like
things like simple things like taking
out dogs for a walk
um you know like getting out of the
house and stuff because i'm
i want to sort of just chill at home and
be happy to just um
you know chuck saying on netflix and
just it's a home all day so
um just things like that just simple
things man and then just having to catch
up here and there with one of your legs
and
one of your mates so um things like that
and then just
first thing when you wake up just you
know like uh maybe just name a couple of
things you're grateful for a day so
um just you know puts things into
perspective so yeah and your body's
feeling
good ready for bunnings cup yeah
i'll get there right it's like uh you've
got four weeks um i had my first lease
for the club rugby
i had out last week and um that was uh
yeah that was all right it was just um
more just you can do as much writing as
you can hey but
uh rightly for this is just stunning
i'll say the
effects and stuff take away um take away
your breath a lot more so
now it's all good i'll get there i've
got another four weeks to
get um a few more minutes now about but
yeah i think i'm just
more excited than you yes so what was
your training like at um the highlanders
you obviously went down there for
um the season but were you training with
the side or when did you sort of pull
out of those
team trainings so it was the week before
our hurricanes came in
uh against yeah the canes i think it was
a home game so
would have been the first round yeah
after a bye week
um so i thought of yeah that's when it
sort of i pulled out then
um and then i probably had like a couple
months off just not really doing much
in the team environment it was just more
focusing on you know
like me being like getting more
comfortable and myself
in the gym and all that sort of stuff
and
so once uh it was the australian came
around
and that's when i sort of started going
back into training with
the injured boys and stuff yeah so yeah
i didn't actually
get to the point where i was back with
the team but i felt like i probably
could have
had to have been like a few more weeks
saying but i went to a pretty good
place where it was good that i was just
you know like training with the injured
guys and then
yeah seeing the other fellas as well
like the team that were playing so yeah
that was
a good experience so when you said that
you were you pulled out of that
hurricane's game so
talk to me about the lead up into that
decision what was the deciding factor to
sort of pull out of that game
oh man so um ah
it was so they hadn't actually named the
team
like do you know how like they sort of
you know like there's there's a team
that they named
and you sort of get a good indication of
oh yeah like you put your hand up in
well
it's a team so um my first
first day back i had that training and i
felt like i trained pretty bad like um
[Music]
yeah it was like more just pressure from
me
just like to perform um
and put my hand up uh and then the
second day
probably that was when it sort of just
kicked in there no like
i wasn't feeling feeling right i wasn't
really like
in the mind frame to you know i had i
did get picked like be able to run out
on forsyth and uh
try to play so which is like pretty big
like
a lot of you know like for me especially
like i've had
times where like i haven't been right i
mentally and physically but i still try
to
push through just the just to play that
saturday or
sunday whatever it is so i think um
yeah it was that that second day man was
when i was just like no
i can't do it you know like something
might really kick off it if i try to so
yeah so you mentioned that you sort of
had that feeling before but you'd push
through
when you'd pushed through in those
previous occasions had you played well
or did you notice that your game was
completely off and did that sort of
impact
why you didn't want to play that game
yeah so i've had times where i've like
pushed through and like i've played
played real well but then i've had times
where like i've just played like
you know i haven't played the best footy
that i've played like on there but i
just wasn't there
and um i think it was more just about
actually putting myself first but as
well as that like
realizing that what was best for the
team was that i was in a better head
space so
yeah like that's what i meant by like i
just sort of started to dictate like
how how i felt of myself as a person
yeah i just didn't want it to you know
like
the whole reason for us moving down was
to have a fresh start and
you know like i just felt like that
cycle was starting again for me so
and that wasn't like that wasn't going
to be healthiest especially with us
moving down being our first year so
crazy it's cool to hear right but
before we get too far i do want to i do
want to go back to the start for you and
get a bit of a background so
um give us a bit of a rundown on what
your life was like growing up
yeah man so um family was
seven uh two brothers two sisters
um i'm the oldest um and yeah like
i'm pretty humble humble is um
was brought up in christchurch yeah um
went to saint these colleges out there
yeah good school
but yeah yeah it was all good it was
just probably
for me anyway i felt like looking back
now it's just
a lot of things that i've seen and
experienced that um
i probably wouldn't want you know father
does come like
my kids sort of experience too so and as
well as that there are a lot of things
that i did
like sort of take into account that um
like i
i learned from as well and you know i
was grateful for as well so
that was all good it was probably just
for me like i probably wish i
played more sports because it was always
just like rugby sort of thing
yeah just you know
and i'm grateful as well because sort of
helped to put me in the position i'm in
now but
uh when i go watch because we watch um
my fiance's our
little brother play and he plays like
league basketball all these
sports so you said it was always rugby
for you
what what age did that start and did you
always want to make rugby our career
from a young age
oh yeah man um yeah rugby was yeah
probably
started playing when i was five um
in christchurch called mary still being
and uh i always wanted to um
to be a professional rugby player like
my dad used to
take um me when i was younger to like um
i think it was like the
window to have those like trials at um
change stadium
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and i've had a
few
like yeah i remember having heaps of
photos and stuff like with white meats
and like
guys like there so um yeah it was
uh something i always wanted to do and i
was like heading into it i had
more of an understanding and just like i
said that like
bit of tools around handling that um
yeah i feel pressure and just that
internal pressure for myself did you
always put internal pressure on yourself
even at a young age or
did you have pressure from your family
your parents or
did you feel a lot of pressure as a
young kid yeah man yeah so
like that's a lot of that came up from
um my like
counselling and psychiatrist sessions
men so it was more like
after games like you know like had i if
i didn't play well
and stuff then you know like i i'll get
a few comments here and there from
the old man and um yeah it was like it
got better as i
progressed and got older but because i
was so young like
you know like i held on to like a lot of
those and
that's why there's so much internal
pressure for myself because i felt like
i was always seeking like my fulfillment
or my um
you know from the game but like someone
else's so yeah
um and you know like especially in you
know two bro
could when i plan and it's more like oh
like i wonder if the coaches were happy
with how i played you know like
well like it all comes down to you know
like um
my man's opinion really but um i think
it's just
having that process and like the
understanding that you've set your own
goals
and you'll be happy that you achieve
them whether you get to run on the field
between three or not so so you're also a
bit of a schoolboy star
like you see for st beads college and um
did you
even then did you enjoy playing the game
did you love just playing the game or
was this sort of pressure still
mounting on you a little bit at the time
i probably felt like i
i did um but looking back at it as well
like
yeah i felt probably probably not as
much because i just keep
putting so much um pressure on myself in
terms of making certain teams and all
that
but yeah like it's all pro it's all part
of it especially in the environment
wherein like
you set high goals you want to achieve
them and stuff but i think it's just
important like
to switch off too having that fine but
for me it was just always like
no i can't do this because like a rugby
or
you know like all that sort of stuff
yeah yeah i got i got better though like
as i played club because i
got back and played um i went to sydney
after my schooling and played with a lot
of my mates
um from school and a lot of my snakes
and well that was cool
nothing better than playing club with um
your mates and stuff so
um yeah that was that was cool and then
yeah just
keep kicking off from here so then the
northland contract came about how did
that how did that one come about
just from your club footy yeah man
i moved to melbourne oh cause i felt
like i did a pre-season with him
and um yeah dale dale mcleod reached out
and said look
um if you want to come back and try
try play club here and see how you go um
and yeah if all goes well then you'll be
picked up but
yes i i didn't want to at first i just
wanted to stay in melbourne
yeah i just think it was yeah to the
fans and stuff
um but it was probably good that i did
come back
and played um otherwise wouldn't have
happened what was your plan gonna be in
melbourne
melbourne storm
there was just one contract left so yeah
so
and the southern i'll end up getting it
so
like after that that's sort of what like
jeremy i was like oh
like i'll try and i ended up back home
and see how i go
so um i think it's just yeah
just the timing sort of thing and yeah
obviously opportunities elsewhere
awesome to stay loyal to you know the
province that you grew up with but
sometimes it is best to sort of move and
you put your hand
in somewhere else so that was so good
and you definitely made an
impression you you pretty much played
every game that season oh you're one of
northland stars that year
straight first year of um npc how did
you find it
yeah it was it was all good like um
it was pretty funny like you know like
watching
watching back at um some of the games
but yeah it was
it was a real enjoyable in fact that was
my first season and
i think we like played like there's a
game like the game of three hearts
and that was the most um most memorable
one was when
we played uh the abs and um
counties played as well so that was cool
yeah
bit of a realization that you could
compete with some of the best players in
the world was it that sort of feeling
after that
yeah yeah like gave me a lot of
confidence too but yeah at the same time
just showed me like
how fast that they played the game like
it was certain just like
how technical their roommate so um that
was the biggest thing
did you feel confident going into that
environment i mean you looked like
you're always confident on the field did
you did you feel like that as well
deep down yeah i think um the club
season had a bit to play with it because
i
i did have a pretty good club season and
then
i just felt um that i'd done the work
there and
like leading up to it in terms of
fitness and stuff and then that just
yeah like gave me the confidence to sort
of just
back myself really because and just sort
of try anything because a lot of it's
just you know confidence hey like
um drawing from that to play your game
so
um i did have like goals in that there
as well like that yeah
um because that was real big on just
setting those goals
but like i had like numbers that i
wanted to reach competing with the super
guys and stuff
yeah so he he set out numbers that you
know like these these are what the
outsides of super getting so
um if that's where you want to get to
like that's what um
you've sort of got to get so eventually
got there like it wasn't all smooth
saying like i remember i ran like a
16 something uh yo-yo and i was like
and that was after like i ran like an 18
something like a month before so
it was like a real up down but um you
eventually got there and
yeah sometimes like it all just really
comes down to how you play on the field
really
yeah but yeah it was all good like
um real grateful for my experience and
you obviously played well enough to
impress big man papa coops um colin
cooper
got you down to the chiefs uh i think
you're in your set after your second
year of
mpc yes it was my first year um my first
year but i got
i didn't really play much there um so
rings was the coach at the time oh yeah
um i met with him because i was either
going to go
oh i was going to go to the blues then
it was literally like the day before
they
finalized like contracts and stuff that
the chief sort of put an offer in so
i just went in through and met with both
and then you just ultimately decided the
the chief so i did like a day trip dale
drove me down to hamilton
and drove me up to the blues and then
back back up to funners
so it's like a bit of driving and
it's all good did you find that an easy
decision i always found like
those sort of times decisions pretty
stressful did you find it stressful
yeah man girls are a real stressful man
like i
i keep starting down i was like man i
don't know what to do like i don't know
what to do
i keep saying like you'd rather have
you'd rather be in that position and
you know just none at all so
yeah just like sleep uh but yeah just
like
took down the positives and the [ __ ]
and stuff and just hold them
ultimately decided the chiefs would be a
better fit
and how did you find it going down there
yeah it was cool like i
was never sat first last year dudes like
playing missing
and crowds were still around so uh
real nervous at first um but like those
two were like the first ones to come up
and say hi
yeah so that made us yeah made us feel
like real at home and stuff and yeah and
to me as well so they reached out
and that was cool so as the season wore
on like
got slowly like more comfortable a bit
too comfortable i reckon like
that like i was good man like um yeah
especially like getting to know those
fellas and
you know what made them too concerned
absolutely and your debut
how was that one yeah that was cool so
that was in front of my family in
melbourne
so yeah so i ended up working out i'll
go with the yellow card
but
uh one of the winners i didn't mean to
but um
you know i just think past the
horizontal one and you got
yeah that was that was a cool experience
man like um i remember that game forever
so
that's cool how did you handle that were
you hard on yourself or you're
not too bad back then yeah oh i wasn't i
wasn't too bad i
probably was like um yeah more like
around my performance and stuff
probably just because the other boys
were saying no no it wasn't too bad
it wasn't too bad just more um probably
just pushed a bit too hard
got him past the horizontal line so yeah
i think they
appreciated the the aggression and stuff
that was probably just
too much yeah but you played some
awesome games for the chiefs over those
i think you're there for three years any
any games that sort of stand out for you
um i reckon the couple in fiji so uh
yeah it's supposed to so the ones in
fiji so yeah the landers down the seders
we're both probably the savers more
because we came back from like a
real big deficit in there just managed
to
to get home so that was a big one um and
you made it better that um beyonce had a
holiday afterwards so
[Music]
somehow if they can work out what oh my
obviously one's covered in that sort of
um it's controlled like
surely take like a game or two back
there yeah that's awesome it always
looked like a cooler case you know they
get right in behind it
they love code oh 100
big timeline and not either side
as well so now it's cool atmosphere man
they love it
so how did you find um being coached by
colin cooper
um yeah he was he was good man like um
everyone real cared about the boy's ear
he was probably the first one that sort
of recognized like how hard i was on
myself
yeah in terms of because i had a game
and it was funny enough i was against
the camps
and respect because this is when i got
real bad around
just around me like how
i sort of um perceived myself based on
performances and stuff
yeah um yeah had a chat with him he was
the man by like real
kids that were leds and um big around
like
you know like their families and stuff
that i had a commonwealth home after
that game and
sort of set across from them and they
just asked if everything was all good
and just to stop being so hard on myself
and stuff like
um like rugby's or just from one part
one part of my life than that um but at
the time i was sort of like oh
just sort of went in in one ear and out
the other
and i was more worried about my
performance and stuff but
um yeah and then eventually well i just
broke down in front of a man like i just
started
crying um and
to my surprise he started to cry too bro
um
just for me like just really showed me
like
you know how much the skylight actually
actually cares about men's stuff you
know
um he's like quite a reserved dude like
he won't say much
yeah but um yeah when i
did have that convo like you know i was
just like sharks like
um you know what this guy really cares
about just like me the person
um and then you know that for me like
that's i think that's why
whenever i sort of ran out there um i
just wanted to put
my best foot forward for him as well um
he said he's a good dude man yeah
no like you said he he was he is a top
man he really cares about the boys and
i mean he got under a bit of scrutiny
for a bit there with his coaching but
mate nothing yeah no complaints yeah
yeah because i i know like he was he was
put in there like real last minute
um and you know like i think
he you know he's did his best and people
just don't really appreciate you know
you're starting there late and you know
got us through some finals you know
quarter finals yeah so
what was your biggest fear around um a
bad performance
you know how you said like you you
wouldn't really go out and stuff so
if you had a bad game what would that
look like for you post game
uh supposed game yeah from boys didn't
know straight away like i just
sort of just just hide away in the
corner
and the changing room bro and just like
head down bro
like just wasn't there um post that
just wouldn't want to do anything like
wouldn't want to go out
um or even like the next day just
wouldn't want to really do anything
really just
stay at home and just landed around and
stuff and
it was just oh my big scare for me but i
was probably just thinking that
people were going to judge me on how i
sort of played and like if
they see me they'll be like oh that's it
quite a didn't play so well
again like me thinking like overthinking
things and
they probably didn't even like watch the
game or even you know but i'll just
start myself now
are you guys like you know just like
hide away until like
monday or something would come and then
go back into training and
would go from there but something i'd
always and this is like
yeah something i like always avoiding
those one-on-ones oh yeah
yeah man so um unless i knew it was like
oh i felt like i played real bad
then i'd go but like even if i had a
good game i'd be like nah
i don't want to you know like it was
like something i
never really did um the whole time i was
sort of playing up there at the chiefs
or even the
miners and stuff um yeah i think that
that gave me quite a bit of nerves
um just because i was like oh you know
like what are they going to say about
that you know that's the best way to
learn too it was just
i was just obviously overthinking things
again yeah
did you often get comments from people
in the street or did
people often recognize you because i
feel like when i was playing
i was quite lucky that no one really
knew recognized my face when
when i whether i'd go out with like a
all black or something one of the big
dogs i'd
always be popping stuff and i'm like i'm
glad that no one really knows me after
that game because like
like you said when you have a shocker it
is it can be quite hard to go out and
um front the public i think um
i didn't have as many like when i'd be
out in
public and stuff it was more just on the
yeah on the field but
um where i'd sort of like cop it and
stuff
um no i'm not really like off the top of
my head
like i was always sort of like just oh
but i'd be keen to get a photo and like
positive stuff a lot of mine came up
from the from the field and
you know there's all that stuff when
you're on there so i just took that with
me and thought that what
you know they might be on the street and
stuff yeah would make you
yeah thank you thinking it's way worse
than it is eh
and just playing yeah yeah yeah
i've seen like a lot of boys like like
copper
especially on social media man like um
you know it felt real bad for them
it was something like real constant like
just every week like you see the team
get named
don't just like tear
and you know some of the boys were all
young too but just real commend them
that
you know they didn't let it you know
affect them like too much and
um you just eventually sort of proved
them wrong so yeah
that was awesome to see so where were
you at with social media in your career
did you were you a big social media
user and did you cop much on it um
yeah i think i sort of like what because
i'd see
my parents comment on a lot of stuff so
like
if they'd seen someone like comment
about you know how i played and stuff
you know i'd have to pull them back and
be like hey
like come on but um
talk to them but i think at the same
time you know they're just being parents
um yeah they try they just look up for
me but
i always said like i'll just let my
performance sort of take care of that
and
if if they don't like it like and they
don't like it um
but yeah it was just yeah i
got used to it and stuff but it's just
like yeah it's just slowly hacked away
as well but
take a toll on me and yeah that just i
think more
put more pressure on myself yeah in
terms of
you know just wanted to obviously prove
them wrong but
if it didn't go right then um
yeah it would just like be that constant
cycle that i was talking about just week
after
week yeah it could be quite draining so
yeah social media's got such a positive
in the game but it can also be such a
negative way like you've seen the
positive side recently
being able to open up help so many
people but throughout your career
obviously you would have felt so many
negative influences from social media
where you probably felt like
man i do not want to be on here oh very
good time man
good time nothing yeah it's gonna be
there right like
um it will be people that you know like
don't agree with
with certain things like um and or how
you play and stuff but
yeah like i said just having those tools
and then
i'm understanding that sometimes you're
not gonna play well but you know it
doesn't define you as a person so
yeah and then let's talk about your move
down to
the mighty tasman marco how did that one
come about
yeah so um because i knew our new uh
ring
[Music]
yeah um and then you're like i'd talk to
like next and
those boys like finn as well and you
know they're saying it's like walking
down the air and
and then yeah eventually like put pen to
paper
and um just went down and broke like
such a good place to you know especially
for those three months man like
um and the group of boys as well were
awesome
um yeah my partner really enjoyed it too
and yeah they're just like real
tight-knit group eight um
i think a lot of them have played mitres
together anyway and yeah
um yeah i really enjoyed it man like
that was awesome even the weather bro i
swear like
didn't rain so nice
it's so nice you know what you'd have to
drive
like i don't know what the road's called
but you're just driving it's just like
the sea's right there
heaven what a sight to like you know
drive by like that time in the morning
just to go to training just like there
but yeah just yeah because the next two
years i've just ended up standing
in hamilton just because we're sort of
bouncing back and forth for that time
yeah that can get hard
that's one part of um super and mitre 10
that can get really hard is having to
bounce and move a family and
dogs um between regions like sa
yeah yeah so yeah they're made of like
um
hard for my um partner to settle too so
yeah
for the both of us was going back and
forth so that those two users were good
what with white kettle too so
um just sort of gave us a you know
foundation to build on and then
yeah just the move to stags was just
more around i just wanted to play off my
bro
like it's always been like a dreamline
to to suit up against them and
um yeah like really looking forward to
that and
just sort of helping them where i can
and then helping me so
yeah so how old is your brother and
what's what's your relationship been
like
uh so my brother yeah he's uh i think
he's 22
yeah yeah in our relationship bro has
gotten a lot better um
we've always been sort of tight but like
never really talked about
sort of just the upbringing and like how
you know how troubled that was um
because
yeah we just sort of turn a blind eye to
it and think
oh you know i just didn't want to talk
about it but this last like a couple
years
like has been real big like because he
went over to italy and
he got about home support so that was
his reason for
um moving back and yeah since then like
we've been like real
open about just making sure
you know that he has someone that he can
talk to and then
obviously i have someone that i can
another person i can yarn to as well
so um yeah our relationship has gotten a
lot stronger in terms of
like we're already pretty strong anyway
but we just never really talked about
you know like how our bringing that
affected us
like he's not really want to to yarn
about that stuff too and not really want
to yarn
like like really anyway so that was big
luck
that i got to sort of see that side of
them um
yeah that's cool so what what part of
your upbringing was um
quite hard like you've mentioned a few
times so what was it about your
upbringing
that was so look it was it was quite a
bit man like
just um oh yeah a lot of things man
like um you know just things we sort of
wish
we didn't really see in a lot of
experience because
we just felt you know like it wasn't
something that us as kids
should have experienced um especially
growing up
um but it was just like that cycle of
like it was what my
old man went through yeah so he felt
that you know like it was his way of
dealing with like us um
phil was misbehaving or just like things
like that so
it was his way like it was what he sort
of um yeah
got bought up on and yeah he just felt
you know it was
it was the only way but um yeah just
sort of pushed us
more away from him at the time instead
of gravitating towards him
and yeah like it's it's our relationship
with our my dad anyway has gone better
now
because i told him quite early on that i
was you know going through this and
stuff
and it's been going on for a while and a
lot of it what came out of my
psychiatrist
and counseling session was that it was
to do with what i experienced and the
trauma that i
experienced as a kid yeah um and all
that so
and it didn't like that convo didn't go
too well at first like he's
pretty staunch man which is like nah but
um since then like it's been good it
probably took like a couple weeks or
three weeks and
you know we had another convo and he
sort of realized that
actually like like something wasn't
right and yeah he ended up
getting counselling two men so i didn't
even yeah so i didn't even like
and he'd been um had his brothers and
stuff had always tried to to yarn to him
and tell him that uh
menu might need to go like see someone
about this stuff and
but he was always like nah um just
pretty staunch i was like no
well i don't need that and stuff and a
lot three weeks later after our first
convo
just i messaged him and he missed
backstage he's getting counselling and
stuff and
you know like he apologized for
you know some of the stuff that happened
um to us as kids and
um yeah so that was like that was cool
man like because i didn't even
you know mentioned to him that like i
was getting counselling or anything like
he just been on
like he felt like now actually i need to
go talk to someone and
um open out open up and you know like
get another perspective
on on how he sort of did things so
um that was real cool um and yeah we've
been in touch um
just checking in on him and how he's
doing and how this counts he's gone and
he does the same to me so
oh it's cool man that is cool it's good
to hear so when did you first think
of going to a counsellor like what age
were you going and what sort of impact
did that have on you
um so excited like i wish i did reach
out when i was younger and stuff
but yeah it wasn't until literally like
this year man and that was because
i just like i said i i felt too scared
to
to sort of reach out because i felt like
it might affect
my um footy and stuff like in terms of
like selection and stuff so i felt like
nah
if i say something like they'll be like
no this guy's not usually writing stuff
to
to take the field and don't lose trust
and stuff but like i said a lot
before that was me overthinking and
stuff and
yeah like it wasn't until this year like
not long after that cain's game like it
took me probably
oh maybe a week or two because i had to
go into the
the psych ward anyway just because i'd
like that was when i was real bad like
just
to go real bad just in terms of by the
things i was thinking and like
not wanting to be around and stuff oh
really yeah yeah so i've got that bad
bro that i was just like no
like um side to chicken once a week but
they would ring me and be
like oh like how you going stuff and um
like are there any like dark thoughts
and stuff and
um yeah i'd be like oh like not too bad
today or
i'd be like yeah it's been pretty bad
today yeah like those first two weeks
just like i felt like no this isn't
going to get any better
but like our pdm sonia always said that
the first two weeks was always going to
be hard especially adjusting to
because i'm still on meds and stuff too
bro yeah
yeah like adjusting to see the mids and
stuff and like for them to kick
in so yeah the first two weeks was hard
because i
wasn't doing anything like you're
missing the boys and stuff and
like wasn't training so i was losing
weight and i'm
real like self-conscious around my
weight and stuff um
because i was bullied as a kid like just
because i was
quite skinny and stuff oh really through
school yeah
yeah man yeah it's just like in general
like um up until i was like
yeah probably 18 or something like i was
just saying that a lot of these
but you know like some of it was like a
bit of banter and then but some of it
you know like was quite
like sort of at home as well just
because i knew that
because it was something i was real
self-conscious about and
yes i lost heaps of weight as well and
like that wasn't like for me like
it didn't give me much confidence and i
just felt like everything else wasn't
going right like rugby wasn't going
right and then
yeah like after those two weeks man it
just started to look up
so started to go to the gym with my
partner and
she worked at a gym across from the
hollanders
and i don't know i felt like you know
like i had no confidence in like myself
like
what i like looked like and you know it
felt like so
um i don't really want to go gym but
because surgeon was
pretty quiet yeah she just said oh
she'll talk to her boss and see if
until but if i go in with her and yeah
just sort of like worked on it from
there
and set a few goals that i wanted to
achieve over there
like next sort of short period like two
weeks in terms of just
getting my weight back on and like that
was something like ticked off that could
give me a bit of confidence and yeah
i put all that i dropped like 10 gigs in
the space of 10 weeks but
in the space of two men just from eating
and stuff
that was awesome for me like gave me a
bit of confidence and then yeah just saw
a snowball effect and then
everything else sort of just started to
go a bit better and
like i said then there were days where i
was like oh you know like nah but
i'll just say to my i say to sev that
you know i wasn't feeling too good and
stuff and
you know should just reassure me and
just support me through it and be like
no
it's all good it's just another you know
like those days will be there just gonna
do things to
to make you feel better how important is
exercise you think for your
for your mental state yeah well big time
me because
yeah they're getting taken away from me
for those two weeks anyway
yeah it's pretty big just to keep you
active and
the mind active too and yeah it gives
you confidence that you know you've got
saying
well you did something to give you a bit
of boost for the day so
especially if you can deal with i reckon
that's like why group training is so big
nowadays
you know you're with people that are on
sort of a similar route and
want to achieve some of the things so
yeah were any of the boys really good
with you like when you were struggling
or did anyone really
reach out and sort of help you along
um yeah man so it's schedules are all
bigger like
yeah so like because at first
they told the team that it was just
personal reasons and just sort of
respect my space and stuff and if they
wanted the message they could but
like not sort of feel like they had to
and
all that so i think scott's reached out
like a
i think a week or so after and he was
big around
a lot reassuring me that he was there if
i didn't need anything
and um i think i i had a convo with the
man when i started training with the
injured boys
that was my first week properly and with
the injury boys and
yeah he just opened up about you know
his struggles and stuff and
um you know and that really reassured me
that man like
i wasn't the only one and someone that i
looked up to especially like
growing up and stuff like studs
um hit his troubles too so um for
someone to
you know he he just came over to me and
we're in the jumbo like
supposed to be like resting and stuff
and he just walked over and was like
like um how are you and stuff um
it's like good and then yeah just
started talking about just being real
vulnerable around
that space and um like i always hold
that convo close to my heart because
um you know like that's sort of what
kickstarted
like or like made me feel like yeah like
i can
actually like talk to like the other
boys about it
um and i was like to myself well i
surprised me like how many of the boys
actually you know were
you know feeling that way and a lot of
the time it is like the injured boys
because
you know like that rugby's getting taken
away from them
for a certain amount of time um
yeah it was it was cool man and i think
that's something that'll stick with me
was this
to make sure that like if i am like
playing and stuff
as well like just uh because a lot of
the time it can be just that sort of
playing group and
then your boy on their own sort of
journey back to play
yeah and yeah i think it just made me so
a lot more grateful that that if i was
like playing or in the playing group
just to take recognition in terms of
what seemed
like those injured boys and you know
like all it takes is just
probably you came for a coffee or
anything like that so if i'm even
in that space again like um that's like
something i've learned
big time from yeah yeah like you say
those the injured group is always
it's always a mental struggle when
you're out injured especially long term
and
you can't quite see the end i know a lot
of the guys with concussion
in particular when you don't have a date
to come back on and stuff like that
it can be a real struggle in those
injured groups but no that's awesome to
hear scads is still
still the man he he was at the canes
he's an absolute legendary love that guy
temporaries
man um but yeah it was like him and yeah
i had a
few other fellas too that reached out
but he was like
he was the big one and sort of just kept
like nudging away so yeah just pretty
so you've signed with the highlanders
did you sign for a three year did you
have you got two more years yeah right
so i was there till 2023
okay yes i've got just two more years
down there and see how it goes man
yeah yeah like i'm excited
yeah for the next year or next season to
come along yeah just going to get
some footy under my belt yeah full of
stairs 100
are you confident about next season
confident that you'll be able to perform
to the level that we all know you can
yeah i think
i reckon i'm yeah quite excited about it
because
i could i can't get any lower than like
about how i felt
you know i did this year and as well as
that like
um
[Music]
you know like of yeah i just know that
things don't go right like
it's not the end of the world but just
like that experience this year just made
me realize that there's so much more to
my life than just rugby and i do have
other things that make me happy
um so it's not like the end of the world
if i don't
you know make the 23 or anything like
that but i'm like real confident that
come next year man like i'm like i can
put my best foot forward
especially going down to the sticks and
sort of add value where i can there
and getting to play with my brother i
reckon it's a bit of you know like a lot
more excitement too so
yeah uh already a real excited face
can't wait to set up an instantly mate
how dangerous are the brothers gonna be
down there for the snags he's still
gonna be on absolute
fire ah hopefully but he's he's he's a
different player to me so
um he also keep him in check every now
and then
too much on the field
it's so funny bro i always get told as
well that like everyone reckons he's the
older brother when they first sort of
yeah and then like they see me like
because i think on the weekend
my father's son and her partners like
little cousins were like oh that guy
looks like um
like charles's little brother
oh i get a heaps
but you mentioned about other things
outside of footy so have you got much of
a plan
after rugby have you have you looked
that far ahead i know you're still young
yeah um i didn't really take it
seriously at first like
my first three or four years but um
started looking into the
police this year oh yeah um yeah so
that's cool um
our pdm sort of sorted some stuff
there's like three of us or four of us
that are real keen on it yeah
um so that's something i'm really
interested in um post
post footy um because my your partner's
step dad's uh in the force and
he's like quite what he does like
special tactics and stuff
yeah he showed me some training videos
and stuff and
this stuff looks cool so like yeah it'll
take a while to get to like where he is
but yeah yeah that would be something
cool to
sort of do um i don't know
what else like um i've talked to my
partner about
um becoming a dog like a german shepherd
uh
dog breeder
you know like just because she's always
like dogs so i just sort of started
once we got ours and i didn't really
like
i don't really like dogs i was always
afraid of them but um because they are
shepherds quite from a good line and
stuff so
um yeah like that's something i'd
probably be keen on especially because
um we really love dogs yeah that's that
the dog you'd be one of the greats
yeah don't be unreal i was like yeah all
the
sort of paperwork in edmond stuff that
would have to do but i reckon it would
be like
um worth it in the end oh cool geez i'm
looking forward to that i come get a dog
off you
hopefully yeah
but anyway as always we've gone to our
instagram for some questions and
holy hackers you've come up with plenty
here
lots about whether you're going to be
lacing the boots up with the stags this
season you've already answered that
um you are going to be and you're going
to be on fire but
first question favorite memory at scent
beads
uh probably my kept game against uh
mobile boys man
um it was mine
yeah and cancer we get school yeah yeah
yeah it was cool man like that was my
best memory
nice have you been asked to play for
samoa
no i haven't um i've had lucky yarn
to the coach this year when he came in
but i haven't
been asked um i reckon i'd be pretty
keen to
just be the timing and stuff as well um
yeah they've got a pretty good team and
it's cool to see like a new rollover
like or turnover of new players in there
especially from our
boys half of the blues are from in z2 so
i'll be pretty keen to be something a
little into what
the next year or so will kept looming
how good would that be
okay next question best player you've
played against um
oh they've been heaps man but this part
i've played against
quite quite um i don't really have to
mark them probably i reckon probably
rochibo
yeah yeah richard i mean he's
unreally just holy he's just like yeah
how important he is to
those boys down there and yeah um
yeah just the ninja rugby generally
based he's a freaky
because i've seen him play like touching
stuff and played with them
like a year and often was age great like
18's maybe but he's just taking this
again to another level
[Music]
just absolutely killing it at the moment
isn't he and he has for the last sort of
three years just
absolutely on fire it just
his footwork and just everything anyway
just so you know exciting okay
would you consider moving to the nrl
yeah bro i i almost did last year
oh yeah yeah so i um i got to do to look
into league for me last year but this
was like
um when i was because i've been going in
and out of it like i was saying before
about
um and trying to find happiness
somewhere else but
you know that was just my way of sort of
masking how like i was feeling at the
time you know
but i got the braid to reach out um and
he had like four
same clubs that were interested to fly
me over and sort of um
play that second half of the the nrl
season because stuart would have been
finished
yeah but i was just yeah i couldn't do
it just because i want to hit him play
the game um
before and then two just like for us to
just get up and move
like to australia for the back end of
the season like
it would have been hard as well so yeah
like i reckon i
[Music]
what position were you going to play
wing oh bro because uh
they were saying yeah like center
yeah it's cool to watch it yeah it's a
good game i am i'm the same just
addicted to
supercoach and my fantasy team
oh yeah yeah yeah it just gives you
interest in it i always like even if a
union game's on i'll be like
man wonder how my um boys are going on
the other channel
next question in your opinion what do we
need to do to drop youth
suicide numbers um
well i'd be able to put it down to one
thing where it's probably multiple
things there like
um tough question yeah big time
maybe just checking in on your mates man
yeah um you know all it takes is a like
text or a very like how you're doing and
then things can just kick off from there
because you're
most vulnerable when you're with your
closest mate say like if you're
comfortable to open up to them then you
know that's gonna be that gives you
something someone to
to vent to and um yeah the wrist sort of
will just go from there and um
yeah i've seen those uh stats and it's
it's like real saddening there now yeah
because i've had a few
um especially growing up like um
because we're a lot in church and stuff
too and a couple of boys
have taken their life taken their life
and stuff and
that was like hard and he was a
up-and-coming um
legal player as well so um i i think
there's some chat around like i felt
like you know
just the pressure of um heavens to crack
it at that age
and he was only a young man like he
wouldn't
he would have just maybe turned 18 or
something but younger men
yeah and um so
that yeah those things are like
definitely
sanding man i couldn't put it down to
one thing
there's just so much for you to change
like yeah
yeah just realizing that like talking
was is okay
well that's a good start but yeah like
we say it's a tough question
and going from uh quite a deep question
to not so much best night spot in the
tron
um probably the house is that
the house yeah probably the house um
yeah that's pretty good spot and
all the all the lads new partners go
here too right so
the
okay two more how will you cope in the
future after a setback or a bad game
uh for me um
because i know now that it's like i said
before it's it's not everything
um but after if i do have a
like like sort of a bad game just
just rather than going into that place
um just
talking to the coaches or around where i
do need to
sort of improve and a lot of the time
like i'll know anyway
but it's just um getting their
their opinion just reassuring that too
but um and not being so hard on myself
that's the main thing for me bro just um
and i know that now too like
last week i didn't have the best of
games because
you know i was first going back in the
while i just kept looking at thinking
you know like
i was just grateful that i was running
around playing some some form of code
and just you know rubbing shoulders with
a good good butt
like a good bunch of blokes so playing
off the bow so
um i think that's the main thing man is
that knowing that i'll get another week
to put my best foot forward and you know
it's not
the end of the world if i you know ever
been again yeah that's true like rugby
you are judged on your weekly
performance but there's always the next
week okay like you're only as good as
you play
the following week really eh so um even
if you have an awesome game it's qui
sometimes can be easy to think you're
better than you are and then the
following week you can be brought back
straight down to reality a with a
shocker so that's pretty good
you've got to keep your emotions intact
yeah that's a big thing here look i
reckon like
it's like it is like an emotional world
story like often that's you
something i've learned along the way
it's just um i'm going to have highs and
lows and we are going to have highs and
lows it's just
just recognizing the twos and enjoy it
yeah 100
exactly okay last question one piece of
advice for someone going through a tough
time
um yeah it's okay to
to open up and talk about how you're
feeling like your
your feelings are validate um it'll be
my big one just
you're feeling that way like for a
certain reason
and it's okay to yarn about it and yeah
just
you're not alone really you're not
saying this man can grow just you're not
alone like
there are others as well that you can go
into about
powerful stuff and you've led by example
um by speaking out putting it on your
post it's if
honestly i had so many messages from
people like and i'd even post the post
but people asking to get you on
and to get a little bit more insight
because they could see what a positive
effect you could have on so many people
now so mate
really appreciate you coming on the
podcast opening up being so vulnerable
um i know a lot of people get a lot out
of that like we've talked about
youth suicide rates in new zealand are
shocking at the moment and we need to do
something about it and
if talking about it's the first point on
a platform like this where hopefully
people will listen to it
um well then that's that's what we can
do and to hopefully um
help some people who are going through a
tough time and if you are going through
a tough time
uh please do open up to someone you are
comfortable
whether it is messaging myself or
solomon like either us will be happy to
um
respond to you and help you out if you
are struggling but like i said mate
really appreciate you coming on it's
been awesome to go through your journey
get a little bit of insight into
what you've been going through and mate
super excited to see you out there for
the stags this year i reckon you're
going to absolutely
light it up and um light up the
highlanders backline next season as well
oh cheers thank you so much for the man
bro
no worries right you're a legend thanks
[Music]
[Music]
absolutely
you